[موسيقى]
مؤلم جدا
فعلت المعرفة تمارين عن طريق الجري
[موسيقى]
في الفريق العام ، فصيلة حول فاليرا في
عربة خطوة إلى شروق الشمس
[موسيقى]
لا تنسى كيف تطلق النار
شهادة
كيف ارسم العين
[موسيقى]
من فضلك جرب القابض واضغط
دعنا نذهب من فعل الحق دعنا نذهب
ركبة
الرجاء الضغط كثيرا جدا يجب
كن دواسة للضغط على إيطاليا
في
[موسيقى]
لذلك التقطوا أنبوب اختبار في الرقم 4
قبل التحقق من الرقم 4 في
بدا الملكيت ما هو عليه
صيغة الفيلم المعدنية فهذا معدن
والذي في هذه الحالة تم سحقه فيه
مسحوق الملكيت يتفاعل بنشاط
أضف حامض الكبريتيك الآن
أنبوب اختبار رقم 4 حمض الهريرة
تمت مقاطعته بحوالي سنتيمتر و 2
شيء معجون لميلتين ، وهذا هو
بالتفصيل حول ما إذا كان سيتم تناول ما يصل إلى حوالي هنا
وبالتالي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هنا لإنهاء المكالمة
هناك وردة
[موسيقى]